[موسيقى]
حاليا في المملكه المتحده يوجد نحو 26% من
الفئه العمريه بين 18 واربعه وعشرين عاما
ايجيل زي يعرفون انفسهم بانهم نباتيون
خلال خمس سنوات سيكون النباتيون هم من
سيقود هذا التغيير
[موسيقى]
لا يمكن انكار وجود تسيس كبير للنباتي
اليوم واعتقد يحدث في الولايات المتحده
اكثر من بريطانيا اوروبا الغربيه بشكل عام
واعتقد ان السبب وراء ذلك وانه عندما تقوم
بتسييس شيء ما يصبح من السهل رسم خطوط
المعركه لذلك اذا كان لديك اشخاص من مختلف
الاطياف السياسيه يختلفون على فكره ما فمن
خلال تسييسها يمكنهم تحريك الدوائر
السياسيه ضدها واعتقد ان ذلك تكتيك رخيص
نوعا ما يتجاهل فضائل النظام النباتي
ونامل ان يكون هناك المزيد والمزيد من
الناس يتبنون النباتيه من مختلف الاطياف
السياسيه
[موسيقى]
لا احد يقول انه يعتقد ان التغير المناخي
ليس مهما وانما ما يقوله الناس انهم
يختلفون مع طريقه المحتجين
[موسيقى]